now have you registered yet to vote in
the EU referendum on the twenty-third of
June if not you've got until midnight
tomorrow to get yourself signed up
online otherwise too late one campaign
has thought of a rather unique way to
help encourage 18 to 24 year olds to get
themselves registered so the scene was
set as you can see these young people
weren't really sure what was planned
they thought that they were registering
a devotion in order to make them realize
that every vote is precious what was the
other side of that curtain
what a brilliant idea joined by Henry
Hitchcock's the founder and executive
producer of action productions who
produce the video and they % the
spokesperson for the campaign group wake
up and vote hello two gentlemen thank
you that was very clever who came up
with the idea that was us okay yeah we
just wanted to create something that
sort of felt relevant and that young
people would want to watch and want to
share yeah we also really wanted to
celebrate those that were registering on
the day and kind of give them an
unforgettable experience that was kind
of it quite difficult to get people to
register to vote it certainly looks like
it a lot of people who are the older
population generation will register
youngsters not so interested yeah we
know there's a massive lack of young
people that are on the electoral roll
and like when you look at the general
election last year we had forty-three
percent 18 20 year olds that turns out
and voted first there's nearly eighty
percent of over-65s so wake up and vote
we're neutral and we just think that
this is one of the biggest decisions
that this country is going to have in
the generation or so and it's really
important that everyone is represented
in making that decision and all these
different opinions and perspectives are
factored into that so like Henry's made
this amazing DJ we've got loads of
social content thousands of lights
thousands of shares and we just want
people to go and register because
tomorrow at midnight is the deadline
that's it isn't it absolutely you've
both registered however just checking
how challenging was it to organize
because it some of these young people
when they're walked through that curtain
in fact one young chap went straight
back again Denis was not sure at all
yeah we had well in terms of the people
that came in the majority of them loved
it in fact here the milk to a little bit
yes so we can see that yeah then we had
a couple of people that needed a bit of
persuasion to get through and I think
the only had one on the day that didn't
go through ok and how challenging was it
though to actually organized given that
young people not keen to get engaged are
they they're not keen as we were saying
to actually register to vote but to
actually get involved in this we're
suppose that was a fun thing to do so
you were to a certain extent you would
say come on have a great time yeah well
we couldn't say kind of a great time
because they thought they were just
coming in to register on an iPad so it
was like we had to kind of persuade them
to register thinking they were just
going to be registering and then I guess
the hard thing was keeping everyone
quiet behind the door
communicating the name because we
basically got their names at the door so
it would be like their names jessica the
names jessica and then everyone when
they came in with scream jessica so
keeping everyone quiet and keeping the
surprise through that corridor was but
with the ones that were actually on the
red carpet the lineup they were
obviously all in on the joke and they
all signed up to vote as well we asked
them yet so nothing they all said they
had will try and double check okay why
do you think no is it that young people
don't feel as engaged do you think it's
because they don't think that
politicians think they have a voice or
do you think there's another reason I
think it's actually quite difficult to
speak to I mean we use this time young
people and actually we know that it's a
diverse group of people and politicians
have found it very hard to engage and
that's why you know we're focused on
social media it's a completely different
way of talking to people and our content
is a lot more lighthearted a lot more
fun and actually I think we're just
trying to find a different way of
speaking to people I think people care
people are interested but successive
kind of years have gone by where we've
seen the number of people voting drop
off and we just really determined now to
actually find a different way of talking
to people and I think hopefully there
are some lessons that we can learn about
actually how do we get young people
involved in politics in this decision
and especially because the referendum it
isn't party political so it's a massive
decision that affects young people more
than everyone else really because
they're going to be living longest with
the consequences and did you find that
people were chatting about it afterwards
Henry I mean what people engaged given
that they were there and then then had
registered vote and it was a lot of fun
but were they also talking about
politics yeah a lot of people were
chatting about officers and I think they
were variable on like the whole
experience but we interviewed them
afterwards and they were all talking
about the importance of voting a lot
than what kind of saying they were in
order them selves are having not
registered already and it was good to
have that little bit of extra persuasion
but I think out on the streets when we
were welcoming people in there was a
mixed number i think quite a few people
had registered which was nice to see but
there are a lot of people who are quite
athletic as well and just not interested
in we can even persuade them to come in
and register so it's definitely a mixed
bag now I've thought of a challenge
glastonbury
I'm going yeah have you registered to
vote ready to devote my post and I think
that's something that people really need
to remember it's not just remember to
register before midnight tomorrow but to
get that poster weight sorted because I
know a lot about you can do a proxy vote
as well so if you are going to
Glastonbury make sure so for all people
that are watching Glastonbury is at the
same time isn't it yes the same weekend
yes thursday so it starts on Thursday
which means interrupts with the
referendum so we need people to make
sure they're registered before they go
well I before Tuesday so what do you do
if you want to register to vote how do
you do it you've gone the government
website and you sign up it's basically
it takes five minutes it takes even less
the thing I did it in about a minute and
a half what do you need so if you've got
your national assurance number it will
speed things up but you don't actually
need it so if you want to find it which
will help things go really smoothly it
will be on a pay slip or or another kind
of p62 type form I'm sure we can show
that on screen when somebody's listening
there we go I'm so this is so you see
this form yeah so you online yeah go
start now follow the instructions and if
you can't find that last row insurance
number and you can actually click a
little link and you can input why you
can't find it and then you should
actually like you should still get on
the register if you if you make sure you
make the deadline and to register for a
postal vote more or less the longer the
same thing I did it awhile ago did you
see my tickets are on I did it a while
ago but i think it's similar criticism
everything's on the website so it will
walk you through okay do you think we'll
have a record number of young people
that's phrase again young people
whatever that means is you quite rightly
say Louie coming out to vote this time
um I can't say for sure but we're
working hard to try and get as many
people as possible and you know we've
got loads more stuff that we're doing
over the next 48 hours so hopefully if
you are watching if you know a young
person you know it's not even about
their that the actual way they're voting
it's about saying like come on make sure
that you're even like able to vote in on
the twenty-third yeah I think it's great
we managed to get a hundreds of
thousands of views in two or three days
it's been out and
Louie night she just checked and there's
been a hundred thousand 18 to 24 so
you've registered in the last three days
not claiming every thousand sit in the
last it's not to data sensational spring
great yes in some small part down to you
guys I'm not gonna take any credit for
it down that red carpet it's great to
talk to both of you thank you very much
indeed for joining us we appreciate it
some don't forget to vote thanks a lot
just one